white house negotiators and democratic
congressional leaders met
11 times to discuss a coronavirus relief
package
before president trump took his
executive action yesterday
joining us now from the white house
treasury secretary steven mnuchin mr
secretary
welcome back to fox news sunday thank
you chris it's good to be with you
you just heard speaker pelosi's reaction
to the steps that president
trump took yesterday your response well
first of all let me just say
it was the president's first choice for
us to go up and negotiate a fair deal so
mark meadows and i
negotiated non-stop we went through
every single line item
with them for two weeks let me just give
you a sense of this on education they
wanted a hundred billion we agreed to
105 billion
they then raised their number to 400
billion as the speaker just said they
wanted money for food
we compromised on food we actually
reached an agreement on that
we had the postmaster general up we
couldn't wait let me ask you about
what mr secretary let me just ask you
about that because she kept referring to
250 000
for food relief is that true no we came
up to a very fair compromise we actually
reached an agreement on what they wanted
without long-term changes on policy and
we knocked that off the list
but let me just tell you what they've
refused to negotiate on
we said tell us where you are in a
compromise for state and local
they said word a trillion dollars we
said tell us where you are in enhanced
unemployment
we told the american people we'll keep
it at 600 while we negotiate
for a week or two they refuse to do that
those two issues
they've refused any compromise on mostly
every single other issue
we've reached an agreement and what
happened on friday was
they said well call us back we said to
the president look
now you've got to move forward with
executive action so that you can help
american workers and american people
but mr secretary let's talk about what
the president's actions that he took
yesterday we've talked about what they
did let's talk about what they
don't do they don't provide another
twelve hundred
dollar direct payment to people they
don't
uh restore the payroll protection
program which helps small businesses
that
ran out yesterday uh here's what
democrats said during the negotiations
there are real needs america knows they
have real needs the public is on our
side
but they would seem not to be willing to
go in a direction
that would meet those needs it's hard
when your values are so
different in terms of bubble up from the
working class families
instead of trickle down from above
mr secretary you heard speaker pelosi
says she would like to resume
talks are you ready to do so and frankly
given
these differences in what you heard from
her today why should we think
that negotiations this week would go any
better than
the failed negotiations of the last two
weeks
well chris i i've talked told the
speaker and senator schumer anytime they
have a new proposal
i'm willing to listen but let me just
say you're right we agreed with the
democrats we both want to send
more checks to the american workers we
want to send more ppp
to those hardest hit businesses we've
said let's pass legislation on the
things we agree on
and knock these off one at a time and
they've refused to do that
until they get their trillion dollars
for the states i've also spoke to many
governors over the last few days
we offered more money for the states
they still have 150 billion from last
time
most of them haven't even used half of
the money the governors are saying
we need more money for education we need
help and the president said
we'll give it to you but not a trillion
dollars
uh mr secretary i want to refer to
something that that
speaker pelosi referenced and that was
the comment from republican senator
ben sasse that this governing by
executive action
is his words unconstitutional
slop what makes you think that spending
over a hundred billion dollars that
congress has not appropriated for these
specific purposes
is legal and what happens if there's a
court suit
and all of the actions that the
president took yesterday
are blocked by a federal court well
chris let me just say we've cleared with
the office of legal counsel all these
actions before they went to the
president
the president knew unemployment
insurance was ending
he said let's continue at 400 by the way
the 25 percent from the states
they can either take that out of the
money we've already given them or the
president can waive that
we've been told by the states they can
get this up and running immediately
and i would say if the democrats want to
challenge us in court and hold up
unemployment benefits to those
hard-working americans that are out of a
job
because of covet they're going to have a
lot of explaining to do
as we say you have cut the federal
unemployment benefit from 600 to 400
300 from the feds a hundred dollar this
is a week
a hundred dollars from states but you
say a lot of that would come from
federal money they've already received
do you really think that the that the
hundreds of millions of
the millions of families that lost jobs
because of the virus
don't need that money that they don't
need the extra two hundred dollars a
week
chris let me be clear first of all on
the 25 percent that's coming from money
we already gave the state so this is
effectively a hundred percent
paid for by the federal government let
me also remind you
that obama during the financial crisis
paid a 25
top up so this has never been done in
the history of time
we thought 400 was a fair compromise but
let me just also say
we offered to continue to pay 600
dollars while we negotiate
and the democrats turned that down so
the president sir
that was only for one week that was only
for one week
actually chris we extended it to two
weeks but they made perfectly clear
they're not going to agree on a
piecemeal deal they want to hold up the
american public from getting the money
they need
until they get everything they want
which is just a bad outcome as i said
let's talk about another issue and that
is the suspension
of payroll taxes which even a number of
republican senators oppose there
two issues there seem to be here first
of all suspending payroll taxes
doesn't help the the millions of people
who are out of jobs and don't
have to pay payroll taxes so they don't
get a benefit there and it's also not a
payroll tax cut
it's a payroll tax suspension isn't
there a danger that a lot of businesses
won't pass this these savings through to
workers because they're going to hold on
to the money
in as much as at some point according to
this executive action by the end of the
year
those payroll taxes are going to have to
be paid anyway
well chris we the president wanted to do
a payroll tax cut
we could do the payroll tax deferral
he's going to go to the american people
and tell him that
when he's reelected he will push through
legislation to forgive that so in
essence
it will turn into a payroll tax cut but
let me just also say
for the hard-working people that don't
have jobs that's why we've extended the
four hundred dollars
what we should be doing is let's pass
legislation
on seventy or eighty percent of the
things that we agree on so we can get
money immediately to the american public
schools need to reopen safely i've
spoken to many of the governors both
democrats and republicans
they need this money we have more than
enough money to give it to them
and their the speaker is holding that up
i want to pick up on what you just said
that if the president's re-elected he
would like to
cut the payroll tax the payroll tax is
what finances social security the
payroll tax
is what finances medicare democrats are
now saying
if president trump is re-elected he's
going to gut those programs because he's
going to gut the tax that pays for them
chris that's not the case there would be
an automatic contribution from the
general fund to those trust funds
the president in no way wants to harm
those trust funds
so they'd be reimbursed just as they've
always been in the past when we've done
these types of things
so so you're saying that there'd be no
payroll tax cut there'd be an
income uh tax what increase because
we're all running
already running huge deficits so how are
you going to pay for it from the general
fund
chris there's a payroll tax cut which is
like any other tax
cut to hard-working americans and you
just have a transfer
from the general fund so during fiscal
times
we're we're focused on tax cuts
regulatory relief direct payments to
americans
we'll deal with the the the budget
deficit when we get the economy back to
where it was before
right now we're focused on delivering
very needed relief to american families
that been have been impacted by this
terrible covet
economic issue i
i just to be clear here though the
democrats are saying the result of a
payroll tax cut
is it would mean a cut in benefits for
social security and medicare
to which you say that's just factually
inaccurate there'd be
no reduction to those benefits and the
president's made that very clear
but the issue here is let's pass
legislation
on things that we agree on let's not
hold up money
to education for kids getting back to
school
safely let's not hold up money to
state and local governments where they
need it the
democrats have to come off of a
ridiculous trillion dollar
number to state and local governments to
bail out some of the
the states that were poorly managed well
let me just ask briefly on on that
they're talking 900 billion not quite a
trillion but 900 billion you're talking
150 billion
is there a place in between there first
aid to states and cities
chris they're actually asking for 915
plus the reversal of salt which gets you
over to a trillion but
uh on us we gave 150 in the last bill
we'll give another 150 billion more we
can deal with in january if there's
ongoing issues we can pass more
legislation this will be the fifth bill
we don't have to get everything done at
once what we should do is get things
done for the american public
now come back for another bill
afterwards all right i got about a
minute left and i got a big question and
i'm gonna
count on you to give me a quick answer
let's turn to the economy
and the latest jobs numbers let's put
them up on the screen
uh in may we added 2.8 million jobs
we added 84.8 million in june but in
july
only 1.8 million that's still
so clearly the job creation is slowing
down and that's still
less than half of the jobs that were
lost in march and april
now we see a resurgence of the virus a
spike in the virus and parts of the
country reopenings or slowing down
or even stopping isn't the
vitality of this recovery being
threatened isn't the
the v shape turning into some other
letter of the alphabet
chris is you know we literally shut down
the us economy we're bringing back jobs
we brought back a lot
the president's work's not done until we
get all the jobs back
and that's why he wants to continue to
send money to the american public so
this economy comes back
and everybody gets their jobs back
mr secretary thank you thanks for
joining us you're always welcome here
sir
thank you chris